up next on book tv bob drury recounts
the final 24 hours of the american
withdrawal from vietnam on april 29
1975. he profiles 11 marine corps
security guards who oversaw the final
evacuees and were the last to depart
from the roof of the american embassy in
saigon this program is just under an
hour
so good good evening everyone and
welcome to rj julia my name is john i'm
here to introduce our author for the
evening
um you may know that rj julia is now in
his 21st year
we think it's an extraordinary bookstore
especially in these times
we know it's a busy world out there so
we're glad you're here
time and again we hear from
customers and
visitors of all kinds that it is events
like these that bring authors from all
points of the spectrum to this spot to
this community that make this store
special
last men out
is the book we're here to uh introduce
uh
i thought i'd begin simply by saying
that
my daughter is in ho chi minh city
now i skyped with her
this morning she's a recent college
graduate english major and she is in
saigon to teach english
as you might imagine it's an
extraordinary experience for a young
woman i'm very proud of her because it
was all her doing had nothing
had no say in it whatsoever
she got herself there on her own dime
and she's about two months in
uh spoke with her this morning as i say
it's on skype you know so it's pretty
pretty cool to see her
and
i asked her last week to visit the
reunification museum
and uh
and she'd already been there once but
had not spent a whole lot of time went
back and in a nutshell here's her report
it was eerie
the
reunification palace
aka independence palace
is
pretty much exactly the way it was in
april 1975.
and uh so to
go through it with a vietnamese tour
leader tour guide and to see
in you know the inside those walls and
to hear those stories was an
extraordinary experience for her
yes it was eerie she was the only
american in the group there were other
tourists a pretty good number she said
from all over the world
and uh
her last comment was that they said
almost nothing about the war itself it
was really all focused on
the presidential succession and what had
taken place
inside
inside that building
so that's a point of departure for me
the only other thing i'd like to say uh
in introducing bob is
i'm guessing
that
most of you in this room know this story
much better than i do and i know just
from
some of you who came in this evening
that you lived this story
i was blown away
by the detail
in this book it does read like a
thriller
it's true how did bob and his co-author
know what what went on
almost hour by hour
inside the heads of the men who lived it
he didn't make it up
this
as you will see in the afterword and in
the bibliography of the book this is
based on
extraordinarily resourceful reporting
and interviewing of the people who were
there
so it's a real pleasure
to introduce bob drury author of last
minute thank you john
thank you
and i thank your communist daughter also
well thanks for coming out tonight folks
i i appreciate it uh it's always i've
been here before it's always a pleasure
to be here at rj julia uh
uh i was here four years ago i think for
halsey's typhoon
tom clavin and i wrote that together i
think tom was here two years ago for the
last standard fox company uh i think i
even recognized some of your faces in
here
uh
in fact tom was scheduled to be here but
i i wanted to be here so badly that i
traded him off i traded him the pritzker
military library in chicago for rj julia
so uh so again i say thank you i like
being here
so uh for those people who do know our
previous books our previous
collaborations uh
as you probably know
uh tom and i would like to
chronicle the adventures of ordinary men
in extraordinary circumstances
i like reading about generals as much as
the next guy whether it's patent whether
it's ike whether it's peter the great
whether it's napoleon whether it's
montgomery what well not so much
montgomery he's a briton i'm a good
irishman so uh
maybe we'll substitute brian baru for
him but but i think you get my drift
but as much as i like reading about
these great men what i like writing
about and what tom and i like
researching about is the ordinary grunts
and if you're going to spend several
years
delving into a situation into the lives
of whether it's people who want a
destroyer which is split in half by a
typhoon or who held the hill in korea
when it was 40 below and they were
outnumbered fifteen thousand to one or
whether it was a group of young men in
saigon in 1975 who held it together
when all hell was breaking uh breaking
across
that's why in particular this book last
met out was really such a pleasure
to research to report to interview
the writing and you know that's a pain
but the writing is always a pain and
that's the end result of having fun
doing all this other stuff
uh also those you there's some there's
some scary bang bang in our last two
books in fox company and halsey not to
say that there isn't scary bang bang in
the story of the fall of saigon
there is and there are
brave young men who did not come home
alive from
from that fall of saigon but they didn't
make it out of that chaos
but uh
but we feel that that last man out is is
it it's one of our best character
studies
and
the men that we interviewed the after
action reports that we read the oral
histories we delved into
it just it painted such a wonderful
picture
well perhaps wonderful is not the right
adjective it painted such a vivid
picture of what was happening in these
past
36 hours
as the city of saigon
and the nation of the republic of
vietnam south vietnam fell apart
now as i said this is kind of a
tick-tock book of the last 36 hours but
i think i'm gonna have to set the tone
here i'm gonna have to give you a little
background so what happens as i'm sure
some of you know very well in 1973
the united states south vietnam and the
republic and north vietnam the
democratic republic of north vietnam
signed to paris peace accords
now according to those accords everybody
hoped and wished uh especially in the
united states that we were going to have
another korea situation that it was
going to be a country divided into there
was going to be a dmz there was going to
be a peace line for whenever the north
vietnamese never had any
idea of standing by these accords they
were constantly probing probing probing
they even were allowed to leave men 130
000 men construction workers in
on the soil of the republic of vietnam
finally in this in the fall of 1974
led by a
charismatic
and strategic and tactical genius
and unfortunately named genius general
general van tien dung
uh they decided to invade
they broke the paris peace of course now
we knew they were doing this we had
satellites we had b-52 photos we had
everything
but congress was just so sick of the war
in vietnam we were out we had some men
we had marine security guards msgs at
consular at provincial consulars we had
a a platoon or a half a platoon in
saigon we had some advisors in we just
didn't want we were in the middle of
depression here in the united states or
recession i'm sorry we just didn't want
to spend any more money we just wanted
to kind of wipe our hands of vietnam it
was a bad deal it was a dung didn't
believe that he thought us capitalist
running dogs we have something up our
sleeve so he probed at first sending out
scout teams sending out small combat
units
they met with no resistance
the south vietnamese army the arvinds
the army of the republic of vietnam fell
apart their officers deserted
men were
men were left leaderless nowhere to go
did not know what to do what happened
was is after a while
general dung the north vietnamese
general dunk said you know what
the americans aren't going to do
anything he was expecting a b-52 strike
like the last time north vietnam vietnam
had invaded south vietnam it never came
so gradually he picked up speed and he
picked up speed and the north vietnamese
army 150 000 men more than 150 000 men
sluiced through
south vietnam
like there was like the mississippi
right now it's loosing through through
the gates
the gates that it's over running
provinces cities fell plateku fell way
city fell danang
a beautiful little port city of half a
million people became a swollen seething
cauldron of
arvind deserters arvin retreaters
civilians on the road the roads were
just as the orvins as the south
vietnamese soldiers retreated into da
nang they raped and they looted and
civilians we had so scared the civilians
about what the godless communists were
going to do to us everybody just became
this swollen city
and finally we decided we have we have
to have a plan we have to get people out
of here what we tried to do is we tried
an evac both a fixed wing and a
helicopter out of danang fell apart
immediately in large part because our
own allies our former allies the arvins
thought we were cutting and running
which we were
and started firing on the american
aircraft coming in
the msg unit the marine security guard
unit a small unit in danang got it
almost got into several fire fights with
their ostensible allies until they were
finally snuck out in the back of a
garbage truck finally a sea lift was
instituted the us and south vietnam
took as many boats barges ships as they
could sent them up there and it became a
total mess women were tossing their
babies into the water arvin units were
boarding fishing smacks throwing
civilians overboard old men and old
women just throwing them overboard and
commandeering these fishing smacks to
get south it was just it was a really
it was it was ugly there were no arvind
commanders to us no south vietnam
commanders to keep any kind of order and
we learned something from da nang and
that was ooh
a sea lift from anywhere else is going
to be kind of dicey
so uh
so now
general dung he hadn't planned on taking
saigon until
perhaps late in 1975
but most likely in 1976 after the rainy
season
yet here he is he finds himself
this started in late 1974 in early april
mid-april 1975 he finds himself with an
army of 150 000 people encircling saigon
he's going back and forth with it dung
was a smart man he had been a soldier he
was the only member of the politburo who
was born a peasant he was a soldier of
the soil he liked to call himself he was
an athletic man if i knew how to work
the clicker i would show you a photo of
him maybe i will later
but
but he he he knew that now was the time
to strike
it was just what were the americans
going to do the americans in saigon now
as i said there was this marine security
guard battalion but it wasn't really a
battalion was between 50 and 60 people
and
three days before
the seventh fleet which was cruising the
waters off south vietnam and
international waters out on the south
china sea they sent in a platoon of
fleet marines early reaction commando
types they came in wearing leisure
according to the paris peace accords we
weren't allowed to have more than x
amount of soldiers in south vietnam and
the msgs pretty much took up that quota
so they sent 50 young men with haircuts
like mine except for more hair on the
top come and they had them wearing
leisure suits and carrying their guns in
uniforms in duffel bags i remember top
valdez who was the nco in charge of the
msgs in saigon so yeah that's really
going to fool the north vietnamese
they're never going to know we're here
so we got saigon and there's all kinds
of americans still in there not only
civilians but
state departments spooks cia
there's army advisors air force advisers
navy advisors but let's face it the two
main players in saigon right now are the
ambassador
graham martin an elegant man tall
shocking a shock of white air always had
a jaunty cigarette dangling from his
lips unfortunately
he was a young man he was only in his
late 50s but he looked about 75 because
he was sick
he was physically sick he was had
walking pneumonia
and he was under the mental stress that
i i just can't imagine being under he uh
not only the walking demon he was taking
drugs for an old car accident and he was
deluded now when i say deluded i'm not
trying to be pejorative but he thought
he was the only man he was the
ambassador he was the man in charge in
south vietnam he thought he was the only
man who could cut a deal
with the south with the north vietnamese
who are slowly but surely encircling
saigon
and he would not call
for any kind of evacuation because he
thought a deal was imminent his powers
of diplomacy were going to cut a deal
with the north vietnamese he was going
to bypass general dung sitting out there
and ben hoa 18 miles away he was going
to use the russians to put pressure on
hanoi and it it was delusional
so
his counterfoil so to speak was major
jim keane was a marine major he was in
charge of the msg battalions from new
delhi to tokyo but of course saigon was
the biggest msg
uh post at the time it had the most
marines it had even more than moscow and
it was it was considered a combat zone
even though 1973 paris peace accords
were no longer at war it was still
considered a combat posting
so jim keane and his top top valdez his
master sergeant his non-commissioned
officer in charge of these msgs
they tried everything they could to
dissuade
ambassador martin from
trying to continue to think he'd
negotiate
so we got to get the evacuation going i
mean the evacuation that finally
happened was like plant z
plan a was fixed wing from every
aircraft airfield in south vietnam
well that they were counting on play
coup they were counting on da nang they
were counting on way city they were
counting on ben hoa they were counting
boom those airfields are gone there's
one airfield left in our hands in south
vietnamese hands tan
in saigon
and so plan b
was an evacuation by sea well we saw
what happened in da nang
it was a cluster hump and that's not the
words the marines used it was a cluster
hump and people and it was we can't do
that plus the navy
the north vietnamese cut off access to
the coast so quickly quickly than we had
expected
that we said we can't we don't want to
start another war congress is not going
to fund another war so they went all
through these plans they finally got
down to well we got to send helicopters
in
we have a good 150 helicopters sitting
on the seventh fleet we got to start
sending him in but ambassador martin
would not send him in he kept this
delusion that he could negotiate a piece
so finally enough is enough for general
dung and he thinks he's going to poke a
little stick at the americans to get him
out quicker because he knows once the
americans go he's got the country he saw
what happened to the fourth largest army
south vietnamese south vietnam had the
fourth largest army in the world he went
through it like you know what through a
goose he saw what happened up north he
said i'm gonna take saigon then there's
troops down in the bread basket down in
the mekong delta but you know what i'm
just gonna i'm gonna encircle them and
take them the same way
let's get these americans out of here i
don't want to start another war i will
if i have to they're running dogs he
hated us they're capitalists running
dogs he hated us but
my orders are don't start another war
so
before the morning of april 29th
the ambassador martin had ordered jim
keane to split his msg detachment he
said i need extra people out at the
airport there was a defense attache's
office next to the airport adjacent to
the airport it's where we had run
everything during the vietnam war
westmoreland was stationed there all the
big generals were stationed there now it
was kind it was still the same buildings
but it just had advisors and he said i
need men out at the dao because if we're
going to do a helicopter evacuation it's
got to be from the dao this defense
attaches office adjacent to the uh
airport
so
keene's like no i can't split my command
i only have 55 people i can't split my
command
and here's something about the msgs
they're the only branch of the marine
corps that takes their orders from a
civilian they're not in the normal chain
of command
so this what the state department says
usually through a regional security
officer an rso stationed at every
embassy and the rso said send them out
there the ambassador wants them out
there send them out there
so keane went to top valdez and he said
we got to send 16 guys out there you
pick them top
don't get any of my newbies in trouble
now there were a couple kids who had
just come into south vietnam one was
only in there a week another one was
only in there a couple months
valdez is thinking you know what the
north vietnamese want us out of saigon
so badly they're never going to bomb the
airport i'm going to send all my
inexperienced newbies out there
before dawn on the morning of april 29th
general dung rocketed and shelled
the airport with heavy artillery there's
like six thousand rockets and shells
landing every minute
one of those shells
landed right across and this i told you
i didn't know how to work this but one
of those shells landed right
on a uh
a guard post there was general dung
there's ambassador martin there's jim
keane major jim keane there's darwin
judge he had been in country two months
he looks about 14 years i have a 14 year
old son he doesn't look this guy looks
like him there's corporal charles
mcdonald
charles mcmahon i'm sorry charles
mcmahon
they were manning a guard post they were
obliterated by a rocket
dead
ambassador runs out there in the morning
he gets into it with the army general
out there we gotta the airport is the
airfields are now you can't land a fixed
wing
they're cratered
and martin's still in his delusional
state we could fix this we could fix
this and start getting the c-130s in
here
he gets back to the uh he gets back to
the embassy and he fina and major jim
keane jim keane knows his two men are
dead now his two kids
and he says uh i don't want you to
report this to the marine corps chain of
command
major keene says what do you mean you
don't want he said you take orders from
me if they find out these guys are dead
they're going to pull the plug on me and
keene is thinking
pull the plug on you
the plug is already pulled
plug is pulled for darwin judge plug is
pulled for charles mcmahon
that's when keane realized he could not
directly disobey an order from the
ambassador
but he and top valdez were going to have
to manage this evacuation
with the marines they had on hand
so
uh
if i could let me veer off here and i'll
just tell you a little bit about
these marines once again they don't take
orders uh they're not in the marine
corps chain of command they take orders
from civilians and aside from uh
uh
top valdez who had served as an amtrak
platoon leader during the war in vietnam
jim keane had been an artillery man and
a scout during the war in vietnam
and a staff sergeant named mike sullivan
had served as a common man
calling in the lerps the long-range
patrols would call in uh artillery to
him and those were the only three men
who had any experience with war the rest
of these guys were kids
and
uh is
i i i obviously can't go through all of
them but i mean just some of them there
were john gallane big john big bad john
from boston big blonde john maybe the
strongest man in the outfit
he uh
he when he heard charles mcmahon four
days before he got killed when he heard
him in saigon when he first came into
chow and he had his chat accent
galain took him under his wing gillane
was broken-hearted when they sent him
out and he got killed
uh john gillane bobby frayne the bobby
body beautiful bobby freyn i mean these
are so every time i look at a name i'm
like oh he's my favorite character but
then i see the next one bobby frame they
called a body beautiful he had a knack
back when saigon was it was calmer times
a lot of the daughters and
sisters
and even some of the wives of civil
american civilians working in the
embassy would come in and there was a
cro
which was like a pool and a little store
and a liquor store and a bank and
everybody would end up it was in the
within the embassy compound and all
these gals would always end up there and
bobby frayne had this sixth sense before
before word even got around there's a
hot babe in bobby freyn would be out by
the pools you know this it was before
six-pack abs were fashionable but he had
them they called him the body beautiful
uh
uh
oh dwayne gevers the black market king
another guy short little guy funny guy
from
he could get you if you wanted a chinese
porcelain sword if you wanted a french
hooker if you wanted a new carburetor
for the motor pool
the black market king could get it for
you uh and he had this rough exterior he
thought you know i don't make deals i
don't make deals but when every guy when
everybody was in trouble and everybody
was short of money he would pull him
aside without anybody knowing him and
he'd say hey here you go there you go
this will tie you over till next payday
it's that kind of guy uh there's a guy
from right up right up up uh your
neighborhood steve schiller
steve schirler was from summers
connecticut he uh he might have been the
most uh
in-shape guy they called him the pt king
the physical therapy king he was the
cracker shot he lived on a farm right up
in summer he grew up in a farm
shooting little critters out in the
woods behind his back he was uh
his whole life all he wanted to do was
join force recon which is the marine
special forces and he envisioned himself
crawling through the jungles and
fighting in vietnam by the time he got
old enough
uh
the marines if the war was was over so
the next best thing was when he got
pulled as an msg now these msgs what
happens is commanders take the top one
percent they're less than one percent of
the marine corps the commander company
commanders take they pluck the top guys
in their units
and they send them to they have to go
through a selection process and if they
get to msg school there's still a 30 or
40 percent attrition rate so these guys
are kids but they're tough kids and
they're smart kids and they're dedicated
kids even mike sullivan who wasn't so
much of a kid he was in his late 20s
he's the one who had fought in vietnam
he uh he he joined because he got
drafted in 1967
and he went to his father who had been a
merchant marine during world war ii who
would watch the marines land at iwo jima
and one night he came home he said dad i
joined the marines his father what are
you nuts
what are you crazy dad i got drafted the
army's going to send me to vietnam i
know the marines are too but i figure
the marines will probably teach me how
to not die you know whereas the army's
just going to use me as cannon fodder
so
anyway these are the these are some of
the kids that boom
not only the personal tension between
the ambassador and keene but now the
city of saigon is turning into a
churning roiling chaotic mess
they have to keep it together so the
original plan was everybody from the
embassy was going to go over to the
defense attache's office and we're all
going to helicopter out from there well
keane and valdez said nah that's not
going to happen you know people are
going to run to the flag we're not going
to be able to get through these choke
streets saigon is now like da nang
there's two million arvin
whether you want to call them deserters
whether you want to call them defeated
soldiers but the fact is they're walking
around with guns and are very pissed off
at the americans who they're obviously
leaving
so all day this is going on the
ambassador had henry kissinger on his
side kissinger
uh graham martin and kissinger
were kind of the leftover from nixon
legacy and they kept saying if nixon
were still in office we'd be you know
we'd be given the general done a good
dose of vitamin b52
but nixon had been impeached kind of
gerald ford wanted to wash his hands of
it so kissinger had the most to lose so
they kept kept stalling finally
the marines uh uh the marine high
command
uh the secretary of defense
and gerald ford convinced ambassador
martin kissinger it's time to get out
so so begins a day april 29th 1975 of
just manic helicopters in out in at 5
500 feet out of 4 500 feet small arms
fire the entire time is it coming from
arvin's is it coming from nva snipers
who were now they could see the nva the
msgs are up on the roof they're working
24 hours shoveling classified
information into this brace of furnaces
they could see they could look over the
roof they could see firefights between
the nva
and the few
arvins the uh army of the republic of
vietnam who are still fighting who are
still standing tall and fighting they're
watching these firefights while they're
shoveling they shoveled five million
dollars in cash into these furnaces
american cash who knows how many
vietnamese peasters i remember there was
there was a story that steve schuler
wanted to steal some of that money but i
think somebody stopped him
but uh
but that was a full story anyway so all
day long this goes on so
finally during the daylight hours they
managed to clear out the defense
attaches office the fleet marines send a
small platoon over to the embassy now
the only thing that's left in the city
is this one little outpost the united
states san marcia three square mile
outpost and the crowds around it which
had been two thousand which had been ten
thousand which had been fifty thousand
are now sixty thousand and a lot of them
are armed and a lot of them are peed off
soldiers
so all day long day long
this is going on the crowd surging and
some of the stories i mean i can't i
know we don't have time here tonight but
some of the stories jim keane and tom
valdez and to an extent mike sullivan
are kind of like the little dutch boy
they're plugging dike they're plugging
holes in the dike here here they're
coming over the wall here lock that gate
lock that gate and the guys they're
standing there and they have to let in
americans american reporters american
state department guys who maybe were
stuck downtown everybody's got an
american passport and third-party
nationals our allies are koreans there's
a few brits left in town
and they're standing at the gate and
they're lifting people over the gate and
while they're doing it people are coming
up to them and they're opening bags of
jewels
or krugerratz
big john gallane looks down and there's
a bag of krugerrands he recognized that
springbok antelope he knew they were
krugerrands
one woman
bobby freyn's watching one time and this
woman comes her husband's making way
through the crowd with his elbows
the woman's carrying something looks
like a little blue and he goes oh [ __ ]
no
sure enough they get close the husband
takes it
heaves it up it's a baby gets caught
under barbed wire on top
one of the msgs runs up unhooks it but
per orders gently drops it back down
can't take it in
people are coming up
these heartbreaking stories mr na is one
of my mr na came up to an msg and he got
close enough to the gate he's kind of a
withered old vietnamese man and he's got
an old vietnamese army jacket on with a
row of medals and he pulls a yellowed
envelope creased envelope out of his
pocket
and he slips it through and one of the
msgs opens it up and it's from the placo
officers club dated 1967
and it says mr na has served not only
his country but the united states of
america well
please consider that when you deal with
mr na and mr not had one arm
and he starts he holds a thing and he
starts
wash dishes wash dishes officers club
wash dishes and i remember the msg just
turned around and just said who am i to
play god like this
who am i
to to say yes you can come in and in the
meanwhile all the vietnamese that are in
there there's like a thousand vietnamese
inside the compound already they're all
the fat cats they're the ghost soldiers
the sons of politicians that didn't have
to go into the army that bought their
way out fat cats with with with
suitcases and you know what's in those
suitcases they're smuggling out gold
they're smuggling out jewels they're
smuggling out money and these poor msgs
they're on the gates and
i have to make this decision but you
know what even though they were kids
they had to make this decision these are
19 20 year old kids put in this position
who joined the marines you're not
drafted by the marines who joined the
marines to fight for their country to
fight in vietnam for their country
and now they're put in this position by
the politicians and even the brass
it
it was an ugly scene
it went on all night the big sea
stallions you know the chinook the army
chinook the helicopter that's emblematic
of vietnam they were land they were
landing in the parking lot
the uh the ch-46c nights were landing on
the roof they had an assembly line going
the dao is already empty so now it's
just the embassy jim keane the sea
stallions are made to carry maybe 30 35
marines jim keane is packing 70.
vietnamese smaller lighter vietnamese
would let them at first he was letting
him take one bag
after a while no bags no bags but the
crowd so many people are sneaking in the
crowd doesn't seem like it's getting any
smaller this goes on all day all night
they line up every vehicle they have to
form a ring of light so that and these
helicopter pilots were just magnificent
you know you've seen a helicopter take
off like this or land like this
the only room these big choppers had to
come down was straight down
fill up keane would throw 75 on if the
guy couldn't get air he'd take five off
if the guy got a little air straight up
one crash
one crash and boom there goes your
chopper there goes your chopper pad and
the evacuation's over
so
they're coming in on the roof they're
coming in below
it's total chaos
and finally
gerald ford
sends word to the seventh fleet we said
we got to get the ambassador out there
the ambassador what the hell is he still
doing here we were supposed to be out
there 12 12 hours ago
he won't leave president ford
what do you mean he won't leave and this
dithering is going on in washington when
one of my favorite characters in the
book jerry berry
handsome as the days long
still is still is i mean he looks like a
movie star
he's been flying 18 straight hours
he lands on the uss dubuque
maureen commandant comes out the marine
general in charge of seventh fleet comes
down he says
colonel barry
you will take the ambassador out on your
next run
yes sir yes and you don't ask why
you know you're you're a marine colonel
you know you don't ask a three-star why
yes sir i will is the answer
he gets in he's flying in he and his
co-pilot it's dark they're taking small
arms fire there's a monsoon moving in
they can't use the 45 and 5500 lanes
anymore now they're flying ground level
because they have to fly under the
clouds what are we going to do and
barry's like i don't know i don't know
i'll figure something they land on the
roof long story short because i know
we're getting a little long here but
it's just such a great story
they land on the roof he's got the
little the scratch pad here he scribbles
something on it and he one of the
ambassadors personal security unit
guards comes up and says yes what's this
he said direct orders from the president
i'm not leaving this roof
until i have the ambassador on this
and he's like he's like oh [ __ ] man i'll
fly into the ambassador
sure enough he's there for a good 20
minutes the ambassador comes out they
bring him in they gave him the flag even
at this point poor decrepit broken
broken graham martin
realizes that it's time to go
so then word comes the msgs are still
manning the gates they're still manning
the walls
while at the same flight the ambassador
goes on jim keynes gets a message from
the fleet button it up
he goes downstairs atop valdez and he
says button it up top
top looks over and not only are there
still ten thousand people trying to get
in but there are four five six hundred
people that have already gotten in
legally
tom says doesn't even say anything just
looks at him and keen says orders button
it up
so all the marines get together and they
kind of casually back into the embassy
and it gets a little violent i'm not
going to tell you how but it gets a
little violent they shut the door they
disable the elevators they run upstairs
and by this point there's about 60 of
them fleet marines few fleet marines are
mixed in with the
marine security guards
still dark out it's not doing yet
they get up to the roof
boom everything all hell breaks loose
downstairs the people steal a
the heartbreaking thing people outside
the gate stole a fire truck broke
through the gates broke through the big
mahogany doors of the chancery in the
embassy and made their way up the stairs
to the sixth floor where the marines are
like barricaded against them but some
marines are looking over and the 400 who
were left who were supposed to get out
are just standing there and they call
them sticks they had them in sticks of
like 60 people a piece and they're just
standing there with the sticks with
their luggage and with their kids with
their wives
waiting for the americans to come and
save them and once again i'm telling you
people were brokenhearted up there
uh
what happens is we get a
despite there was a brief pause
where the helicopters stood down because
of flying time and an
even bigger marine general in hawaii lou
wilson medal of honor winner he put out
an order he said anybody that doesn't go
and get my marines i don't care what
service they're in i'm court martialing
so they started flying again
they come in
squadron of there's no more sea
stallions can't get them downstairs
scotch c knights comes in jim keane does
a head count
he realizes even stripped of their vest
stripped of their helmets stripped to
their weapons he said i'm not going to
get all my men in
i'm not going to get my msg's in
he turns to top valdez he says top
give me 10 men i could die with
so these helicopters take off
now there's 11 men left
on the roof
a few minutes later the sun comes up the
irony is several
it's the it's the most beautiful
sunrise
that they've it's a beautifully clear
day the monsoon clouds have cleared it's
the most beautiful sunrise that jim
keane has ever seen in his life
uh
in washington henry kissinger holds a
press conference
gets up at the same podium where two
years before he announced peace in our
time after the paris peace accords at
the very same podium he now announces
that all americans who wanted to get a
vietnam south vietnam are out
when he said wanted to get out some
reporters remain behind
and uh
after he sees henry kissinger sees an
eight talking to him he says excuse me
cut short his press conference walks off
the aid whispers and
we've got 11 marines unaccounted for
11 marines unaccounted for i mean
unaccounted for we lose it in the
confusion
what happened was when the ambassador
went out at 3 48 am
jerry berry's call sign the tiger is out
the tiger is out of his cage
in the original evacuation plan the
ambassador was going to be the last to
leave
so they were still working on that oh
the tiger's out of his cage there's
nobody left
so the hell
the 11 marine security guards keen
valdez mike sullivan
eight kids eight tough kids eight
dedicated kids but eight kids they're up
in this roof
uh
they barricaded the door small arm dawn
comes and the small arms fire just
increases that is it coming from
marvin's once again is it coming from
nba snipers probably a little of both
uh
valdez is monkey walking around the
perimeter kind of counting the weapons
you know everybody's got an m16
everybody's got a sidearm we got a
couple of uh shotguns up here it looks
like we got 250 cal machine guns and
he's saying to himself
what is this this is nothing we got 150
000 hardened angry nba soldiers
out there
jim keane senses the tension census his
10 other marine security guards are
wondering where's our chopper he calls a
meeting they all get in a circle they
held up he says listen here's the deal
general dung does not want to start a
war with the united states
if he kills us he starts a war with the
united states but you know what
i've been in action
in small units things go wrong
so there could be a small unit fight we
don't know what's coming through that
door next it could be pissed off arvin's
it could be nva i don't want you firing
back at anyone
i want your
asses in the dirt but he didn't say
asses he said i want everybody laying
low and i want everybody
on their toes we're going to get out of
here we're going to get out of here but
he didn't believe in himself
in his after-action report he wasn't
sure
so
uh
so there's just scenes as steve bauer an
msg from from long island uh he had
smuggled
two bottles he was carrying he had been
carrying him for three weeks in his
rucksack he had a bottle of johnny
walker black and a giant bottle of
johnny walker red he called the msgs
except for top valdez and jim keane
around and they kind of sit indian style
in a circle and they pass
they pass the bottles around
top and jim keane major keene are over
in the corner
figuring well what's going on majors i
don't know top but listen we gotta start
coming up with contingency plans the um
the embassy itself had a rocket screen
it was kind of a a concrete lattice work
to to obviously deflect rockets and
they're looking over and saying man do
you think we can climb down there get
some rope we don't have any rope human
chain what do you think as they're
speaking keane looks over and he sees
there's something going on in that
circle the two bottles of whiskey dead
soldiers but the guys are still there
top go see what's going on
valdez walks over
and just in time to hear bobby frayne
saying
no tiger cage is for me no hanoi hilton
for me
you know we're gonna take a vote right
now if they're gonna if
if those gooks are gonna take my my uh
dog tags i want them to have to dig
through a pile of dead gooks before they
can get their hands on them and somebody
else said let's take a vote
now the marine corps is not a democracy
folks as you well know but
keen stock kind of knows what's going on
valdez knows what's going on
they take a vote
it's a unanimous vote
they vote to fight
they're not going to become prisoners
valdez in the back of his mind is
thinking
in the front of his mind actually he's
thinking
they're not going to come up that steps
they're not the nba is not going to
waste any more men on us he's watching
thompson at the airport six miles away
it's still being shelled still being
bombarded they're just going to raise
the notch on those gun sights a little
bit he's two or three shells and we're
all and we're all dead we're all dead up
here
uh
so they kind of disperse the sun is up
down it's getting hotter
and all the msgs disperse bobby freyan
gets behind his m50 he's got a clear
field of fire of not on the stairwell
but the british embassy across the
street where maybe uh they might take
fire from
uh
terry bennington hard scrabble kid a
hard scrabble just he grew up he had a
dickens childhood
his mother committed suicide
trying to kill terry and his two
brothers but she failed but she killed
herself she tried to blow up the house
his father was an alcoholic who
basically rented him out
to subsistence share farmers who kept
him feral barefoot in a shack to farm
tobacco the marine corps was the only
family he had ever known and he's
looking around and he's looking around
at the 10 other marines out there it's
like 11 frayed nerve ends we're all
connected it's more than being brothers
it's more than being and loving each
other we are each other we are each
other uh
uh dave dave norman a 19 year old from
ohio he's up on the helipad he's laying
he can hear the clanking of the soviet
tanks that the nba is using he could
hear the the treads clanking coming over
the newport bridge and he's thinking i
don't mind dying with these men
i just wish i could get to see my mom
and dad one more time before i die but
if i'm gonna die
i'm proud to die with these men
uh
uh steve bauer or uh uh uh
steve schuler
once earlier in the day they had opened
the gates to let into american reporters
and they had formed a v and steve was at
the end and his arvin rushed him with
his gun and boom bayoneted him in there
and he stuck his finger in there went
into about there and he lost
consciousness for a moment or so stuck a
dirty rag in there and top wanted to
evacuate him out he wouldn't evacuate
unless his guys were going to steve
schuler's now up on the roof he's
picking through some of the clothes
looking for a clean t-shirt or at least
a not so much dirty t-shirt so he could
stuff up the
the the [ __ ] bloody wound he has i mean
these men are
are all alone with their thoughts top
valdez is thinking of his two teenage
boys
not much not much younger than the guys
he's in charge with and he is thinking
how proud he is and if we die up here
somebody better tell this god damn story
the sun is getting higher
it's
it's getting hotter out
uh there's silence on the roof
and the next thing that happens
well if you want to know the next thing
happens you better read the damn book
huh
thank you very much for coming tonight i
appreciate it i'll take
i'll take questions but i i would like
to say something first if i could
actually two things
uh yeah i think a few of you know uh in
my day job so to speak i'm down range a
lot for men's health magazine i've been
to iraq and afghanistan many times and
and uh and i run into these msgs the
legacy of the msg's
uh guardian consulates and uh
and embassies all around the world and
frankly i'm not so much worried about
the ones in cowboy and the ones in
baghdad we have enough troops over there
but i've been to duchamp and tajikistan
and in jamaica and chad and on my way
into darfur and
tashkent
in uzbekistan or monrovia and liberia
and these kids
that are over and they are kids their
kids today just like they were kids back
then these kids over there that are kind
of
guarding not kind of that are guarding
our embassies no matter how you feel and
i don't want to know
uh about our military adventures
overseas
they're the best trained marines
the most dedicated marines
and just like
the marines
the heroic marines i think they will
never tell you the heroic but just like
the heroic marines from saigon in 1975
that legacy continues in the ms
uh g the marine security guard
uh units and i think it's something that
once again i don't know how you feel
about our overseas adventures but i
think it's something we all could all be
proud of
and i am so
and one one other thing i'll say is that
uh
well you know i told you about that guy
lived up the street uh
uh steve schuller he took that he took
that bayonet and he wouldn't leave and
you know he says it's nothing and all
that well you can give him a hand he's
sitting right over there
i noticed he frowned when i said yeah i
was going to steal some money and i
didn't i didn't see a smile on his face
i was like oh [ __ ]
anyway does anybody have any questions
yes sir
that was yesterday today's today yes i'm
assuming that you drew some conclusions
about as you were doing all the research
you know the main conclusion i drew yeah
yeah is it i'm sorry my question is did
we learn anything that's just it you
know the one thing i don't think we
learned now i am not privy to
i'm i you you know and i know we both
know we have evacuations plans for
cattle we have we have evacuation plans
for every hotspot in every snake pit in
the world
but the one thing i do not think we have
learned and i
i have no proof of this i have no
documentation but just from traveling in
these countries from being downrange
we trusted south vietnam too much
this was a kleptocracy we thought they
would help us get out and i think we
might be putting the same trust in
baghdad and cabell and i don't think
that trust is justified that's that's
the only way i can answer that question
anybody else
well listen thank you all for coming i
appreciate it if any of you have a book
you want me to sign i'd be glad to and
uh
and
and thanks
and no questions for steve wait a minute
hold on hold on
no ques no questions for steve
yeah yeah everybody else says oh went up
to here steve was like oh he's a little
nick he's just a little nick
like i got hurt shaving you know
so
tell the storyteller anyway thank you
again appreciate it
[Applause]
ah you know what just for the hell of it
you don't have to film this but i'll
tell you i'll show you
there you go
there's general dung in his younger days
smart guy ruthless guy
uh and the when the vietnamese kicked
the chinese butts after we got out he
was in charge of that
and he retired uh
uh they didn't hang him or shoot him
which is what they have they usually
retire these guys so
uh ambassador martin that's not a really
good photo of him he was more of an
elegant guy but that's a good photo
showing how sick he was at the time he
just was not a well man jim keane major
jim keane who had fought not only the
vietnam war but then was in charge of
the
darwin judge who looks about 14 charles
mcmahon
top valdez of frito vandido
top does he look like an amtrak guy
yeah you would like you would run he's
like you say i met
well i'm not telling you the end
you would still bounce off his chest
okay i gave i guess you know now the
children of al deslin so
just generic photo oh and there's a good
st
dick cheney
donald rumsfeld
henry kissinger president ford
good sub story i didn't even get into it
tonight run down the river from the only
consular uh the only provincial console
we had i had to fight the arvins had to
fight this says kanto yacht club uh six
marines and the consul terry mcnamara
who is none of it looks like hunter
thompson but acted like him so
typical story and there's top valdez
there's mike sullivan nice glasses huh
uh this is right when they formed the v
when they were kind of backing up and
like look at that it's nuts
that's going down the river that's
that's that's
actually that at the time was corporal
uh
steve hastie and he went on to become
the longest serving united states marine
in the history of the marine corps he
only got out he fought in iraq he fought
in afghanistan he only got out last
february
jerry berry handsome jerry berry the
chopper pilot
still handsome
this is the boys on the roof there's a
burn barrels anything they couldn't burn
in the furnaces they would put in the
burn barrels and the chemicals would
burn it
that's uh who is that steve is that
you yeah
that's steve he's counting that cash you
stall
iconic photo everybody thinks it's the
last shopper out
left 18 hours before yes ma'am obviously
we didn't
know everything that was going on there
especially from the story that you're
telling now
but how well do you think that our
presidents nixon
gerald ford and then lyndon johnson
how well do you think they knew what was
going on oh i think they knew very well
you do penetration did you think that
their information was accurate yeah i
mean
mcnamara has pretty much admitted we
knew this this was a civil war we should
have never gotten involved in i think i
think one of the reasons that i
the kind of dichotomy of this book
people have asked me how could we put
the word heroic
in a book about the vietnam war because
i'm not writing about the vietnam war
the vietnam war has been written about
by smarter people than me by
eyewitnesses by people who were there
i'm writing about a heroic evacuation
i'm writing a 36-hour period where a
bunch of kids like steve schuler
ordinary men extraordinary circumstances
but yes i do think the president is now
and i think that's why ford wanted
nothing to do with it
yes sir
i spent a lot of my time
updating the kip
rosters all right
key indigenous personnel
how many actually made it out
well we don't know how many 50 000 made
it out okay but
the only figures we have
about who didn't make it out was the
north vietnam admitted that they sent
i think it was 182 000 to re-education
camps and these re-education camps were
just hellholes dysentery and starvation
and so we'll never know how many died
but we did get close to 50 000 now
because the vietnamese navy
loaded up all of their ships and sent
them out the uh
saigon river
uh no that was
yeah right before that's how my
counterpart got out right
i met him in
hickam i met the planes
thank you for your service i appreciate
it
anybody else
that's okay i think that's it once again
i thank you i thank you for coming thank
you sir what's your name
jack captain captain jack captain u.s
navy retired all right do you read
halsey's typhoon
i haven't really
here i was feeling sorry
let me let me check let me change this
did you buy holes
oh
christ thanks
all the pictures that bob showed
are in the book so um books are for sale
here i will be signing them just on the
other side of the store
uh
tell the story hope you'll take it home
with you thank you all very much for
coming
book tv has over 100 000 twitter
followers
be a part of the excitement follow book
tv